like any good movie adapted from a comic
book with years of history Aquaman had a
few cool Easter eggs put there to reward
eagle-eyed comics fans from fun cameos
to some pretty deep cuts that only makes
sense if you brushed up on your comic
book history here are some of the Easter
eggs that you may have missed in Aquaman
and beware there be salty sea spoilers
ahead it's no secret that tons of movies
and TV shows try to make themselves seem
more real by enlisting the help of real
world media personalities to talk about
the fictional events or characters
you're watching you know the moments
like when Anderson Cooper appeared on
CNN to cover the big superhero Throwdown
in Batman vs Superman dawn of justice
but Aquaman goes in a different
direction
just as folks in the DC EU read The
Daily Planet rather than the New York
Times they also watch other channels
instead of say MSNBC when the characters
in Aquaman flip on the news the anchors
sit behind a desk at GBS a fictional
Network pulled straight from the pages
of DC Comics longtime comics readers
might know that in 1971 Superman number
233 Clark Kent gave TV a shot working as
a news anchor for w gb s pretty much all
of DC Comics superheroes have their own
fictional locales where they hang their
capes and Aquaman's no different the
battle for Atlantis is thrown is one of
the film's central plot lines however we
had no shortage of undersea
civilizations to see as the movie
progressed another scene in the movie
seemed to lay the foundation for a
different superhero who we haven't
actually met in this version of the DC
extended universe during the
one-and-only credits scene we see a
clipping from a newspaper asking about
the identity of Aquaman and the
newspaper itself is the Coast City
Gazette presumably the hometown paper
for another important DC superhero Green
Lantern sure if you saw the Ryan
Reynolds star in Green Lantern movie
from 2011 you're probably already
familiar with coast city but there's
actually a pretty good chance you didn't
see it since it didn't sell enough
tickets to justify a sequel please don't
make the supersuit green
or animated since Warner Brothers
rebooted DC Cinematic Universe after
Green Lantern bombed we've been
introduced to tons of heroes and
villains but except for a small cameo
during a flashback scene in Justice
League Green Lantern is still m.i.a from
this incarnation of DC's movie verse
could this small newspaper clipping lay
the groundwork for Green Lantern's
impending return most DC Comics fans
know that Aquaman has a sidekick who
usually goes by the name Aqualad but
even though Aqualad has had comic book
and animated adventures of his own and
the Teen Titans and the team from Young
Justice Aquaman has yet another sidekick
who rarely gets the respect he deserves
that's right we're talking about topo
The Octopus an eight-armed Sentinel of
Justice who Aquaman taught to play
several instruments at once mostly so he
could play happy birthday should the
need arise
no really as silly as the Aquaman movie
turned out to be James Wan and the rest
of the filmmakers wisely decided not to
go so far as to have Arthur hang out
with his octopus pal however Wan has
indeed confirmed that topo makes an
appearance in the movie anyway he's not
easy to miss he's the giant octopus
playing the drums during the Ring of
Fire battle scene between Arthur and
King orb for a movie set in the DC
Comics multiverse there weren't a ton of
overt nods to comics themselves or at
least that's how it might seem however
there's a distinct possibility that one
of the movie's key locations the sea in
the center of the earth could actually
be one of the most obscure Easter eggs
you could imagine in the mid-1970s DC
Comics published a series called warlord
about an Air Force pilot who crashed
lands in a place called scar Terrace a
lush jungle land filled with fantastic
creatures and dinosaurs and in the third
act of the movie
Aquaman and mera find themselves in a
mysterious land in the center of the
earth filled with lush jungle and
dinosaurs where they're reunited with
Atlanta who's been there by herself for
20 years
while scar Terris in the comics does in
fact feature various factions of people
Atlanta said she was alone the entire
time she was there that might mean that
wherever she bin might not actually be
Skaar Terrace or simply that she never
managed to encounter any of the lands
inhabitants maybe warner brothers will
announce a warlord adaptation coming to
the big screen any day now but in
till they do this easter egg might not
be as fresh as the others
[Music]